- Oh, hey, I just blew it up in there.
You might want to wait.
- Okay.
- Cool.
(happy music)
- Hey, can you drive me to the airport
tomorrow morning at 5?
- Yeah, whatever.
- Cool.
- Yo, there's some beer in
the fridge if you want some.
- Cool.
- Hey, I'm gonna have a girl over later.
Is it cool if we use the TV?
- Sure.
- Cool.
- Hey, I mowed the lawn
'cause I knew you were too busy to.
- Thanks.
- No worries.
- I took down all the Christmas
stuff when you were gone.
- Sweet.
- Cool.
- Hey, I like your glasses.
- Thanks. I like your shirt.
- Thanks.
- Hey, did you eat my burrito?
- Yeah.
- Thanks for being honest with me.
- I'll get you back.
- Cool.
- I haven't started the show
yet. I was waiting for you.
- Oh, cool. We can start now.
- Cool.
- How was your day?
- Fine. Yours?
- It was whatever.
- Cool.
- Did you get the same
sunglasses that I already own?
- Yeah. Is that cool?
- It's fine.
- Can I borrow your new
jacket for my date tonight?
- It's fine.
- Cool.
- Hey, I just won two tickets
for the Superbowl on the radio.
Do you wanna go with me?
- Hell yeah.
- Cool.
- Hey, are you busy right now?
- No.
- Cool.
I just kind of wanted to
get something off my chest.
- What's up?
- I just blew up the bathroom,
so I wouldn't go in there
for another like 25 minutes.
It's bad.
- Thanks.
- Cool.
(happy music)